the figures have just come through from
the Department of Health which gives us
it's their compilation of the individual
nations combined sometimes actually
there's a bit of variation between what
we report and the individual Nations and
what this Department of Health figure is
because actually they record their data
at a different time of day but the
numbers that they've just given us now
within the last few minutes an increase
of 759 deaths taking the total sadly now
to 18100 within the UK confirmed cases
an increase of a hundred and thirty
three thousand four hundred and ninety
five people testing positive for kovat
19 slightly up on the day before which
was 100 just slightly over one hundred
and twenty nine thousand and when it
comes to the amount of tests that we are
doing in the UK at the moment we know of
course that the government is trying to
aim for a hundred thousand tests by the
end of the month slightly more than
yesterday yesterday they were testing
eighteen thousand people within this
24-hour data collection period today the
number is now 22,000 so a slight
increase but still way off the numbers
of a hundred thousand that there aren't
wanting to see as a target I think again
what we're seeing really today is these
consistently low increases really what
we're seeing on a day to day basis
there's a lot of variation the numbers
can go up they can go down because we
are at the moment within this plateau in
terms of the number of deaths and we do
appear to be or we're not really seeing
any great fall in the numbers that were
getting through at the moment